it's Tetum Lathika next routine chime
gets his home this how about the
athleticism showing there but the young
Jason Taylor running down look at this
finger roll a little bit too far out for
it hits the front of the rim but just
puts it right back Indiana
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is this quarter three points in
over five minutes
the Leprechaun on the rim as we've heard
so many times and at the other end I
mean this is a five-point turnaround no
- at the other four young and a three-y
Kyrie Irving for the window
slash bracket challenge Irie in
transition
[Music]
there's avenged
[Applause]
[Music]
36 points last eight points here for
Boston playoff Kyrie depends boom foot
was at Collison I've said it goes Taylor
crying
which led to this three here by tatum in
the corner by the assist
put the gun to the dead
and here take them again
look at all the blue jerseys around them
just finds a wide open Gordon hey turn
around the boys happened for the last
minute for the Pacers you've got a foul
Hayworth there if you're Cory Joseph